This is an underwater cave system recently
discovered by scientists.
– Life has existed there for millions
of years without our knowledge.
With regards to the ecology of these systems,
almost nothing is known.
John Pohlman and his colleague, David Brankovits,
are researching these cave systems to understand
how life can exist here, in total darkness,
and with little oxygen.
– We are providing an explanation for a globally
distributed ecosystem, that was unknown
to science until 30 years ago.
Our primary objective is to go from description
of the animals inhabiting these systems
to, actually,  the processes that allow them to
live and flourish.
Our research in the Yucatan Peninsula showed
that methane and other simple dissolved
organic material that is trickling in from
the jungle floor into the cave systems, and
it's dissolved in the water, that it is being
used by microbes present in the caves.
No one had imagined it operated this way before.
We're hoping to understand exactly how external
factors related to weather, tides, hydrology,
and all these things come together and wind
up creating a model for how the ecosystem functions.
Because these questions have never been
asked before, John and David have creatively designed
their own research equipment.
This 300-meter copper coil will collect a
small sample of water each day for six months.
It will serve as a history book of the water
chemistry in the cave, much like rings of
a tree can indicate the history of rainfall
in a forest.
–  This is the osmotic pump.
It's the osmotic potential between this salt solution and the fresh water: this very narrow tubing will be
connected into the copper coil so the water
is getting pulled from the other end.
This will be something that no one's ever done before.
– Charged.
Ready to extend.
Go.
It's going to be perfect.
This is what we need for the field.
I know that cave diving is not for everyone.
I personally don't get claustrophobic, but
the first time I went underwater underground
it was breathtaking.
What drove me was the curiosity.
I wanted to see what's down there...
We typically penetrate the caves up to one kilometer
when we are doing research.
The cavern environment is the part of the cave system
where you can still see some light shining
in from the sinkhole, but once you leave that zone
you are in the cave that is pitch black,
and the only light there is is the light that
you bring with you.
What's fundamentally important about these
systems is that we have freshwater, with
no oxygen, that contains large amounts of
dissolved material that can be food, but it's
not accessible to the animals living there,
the microbes in particular, unless it mixes
with the oxygen which is coming from beneath,
with the seawater.
So, once those are mixed together, you have
all the ingredients for life, and then you
have growth of the bacteria.
And then the higher-level organisms, the crustaceans
and the fish, they're feeding upon the bacteria
and that's what actually is supporting the
whole food web.
When John and David finish this 6-month sampling
period, they’ll take everything back
to the lab, and hopefully begin to understand
this mysterious ecosystem
that has been hidden under our feet for aeons.
Suddenly, you see a data set
that actually tells you something
about the processes that sustain life in a
cave system.
I mean, how cool is that?
Those are the moments, the wow moments, that
make it worth it for me.
For more episodes of Science in the Extremes,
check out this one right here.
Don't forget to subscribe, and come back to Seeker
for more episodes.
Thanks for watching!